what is the cost of fourteen point six
gallons of gasoline at two dollars and
seventy per gallon so we have fourteen
point six gallons fourteen point six
gallons and each gallons going to cost
two dollars and seventy or we could even
view two dollars and seventy as two
point seven dollars so let's just
multiply it times two point seven it
makes things a little bit simpler and I
think you're appreciate two seventy is
the same thing as two point seven
dollars per gallon so let's multiply
this out so first we have and just as a
reminder when you multiply decimals you
just have to treat the numbers like
whole numbers and then worry about the
decimals later so right now we can just
do this as 146 times 27 and then we'll
worry about the decimals so first we
have a seven times a six so we have 7
times 6 is 42 regroup the 4 7 times 4 is
28 plus 4 is 32 regroup the 3 7 times 1
is 7 plus 3 is 10 so we get 7 times 146
is 1022 now we're going to deal with
this too but this to at least before we
consider the decimal is really a 20 so
we're gonna put a 0 here 2 times 6 we're
doing it exactly the same way we do a
traditional multiplication problem we're
ignoring the decimals for now 2 times 6
is 12 carry the 1 or regroup the 1 we
could ignore these guys right now 2
times 4 is 8 plus 1 is 9 2 times 1 is 2
and now we can add and now we can add
and we get 2 plus 0 is 2 2 plus 2 is 4 0
plus 9 is 9 1 plus 2 is 3 now we figured
out what 146 times 27 is it's 3942
but this wasn't 146 times 27 is 14 point
six times two point seven so now we have
to worry about the decimals we just
count how many numbers are sitting
behind decimals we have one right there
and
and one right there so our product has
to have two numbers to the right of the
decimal so one to stick it right over
there so for fourteen point six gallons
of gas at $2 seventy per gallon it's
going to cost thirty nine dollars and 42
cents